what's popping Alpha num maricons it's
me Mt and welcome back to the heavy
spoiler show y'all know the drill by now
this is going to be a breakdown of Rick
and Morty season 7 episode 8 the episode
were
7869 you can always count on me to
capitalize on any moment to make a
terrible dad joke I'm so sorry so I'm
just going to go ahead and shut the hell
up and get right into it and right away
the episode opens with the return of the
planet of alphab betrium a planet where
the people continents and clouds are all
shaped like letters of the alphabet
alphabet trium was introduced in season
2 episode 5's get schwifty episode along
with Rick and Morty's version of IC tea
an episode that shows IC tea deciding to
uncharacteristically care about the
people of Earth after working along Rick
Morty in the United States government in
order to protect the planet by showing
the cromulons what they got a growth of
empathy that explains why the opening
shots of get Swifty's post credit scene
as well as this new episode start with
an alphab betrium wide shot with the
letters IG GF in frame which of course
famously means I give a [__] to of
course symbolize IC tea giving a [__]
about Earth however although Morty keeps
trying to reference the events of get
schwifty to ice te the IC tea of this
episode doesn't recall those events
whatsoever but while it seems like IC
tea doesn't remember Morty just because
Morty is just some unmemorable teenage
loser to this legendary rapper I don't
think that this is the case the most
likely explanation for this to me is
that this IC tea is a variant the IC tea
from season 2 who was originally from
Dimension c131 the same Dimension that
the Smith family abandoned for the
parmesian universe after the entity Mr
fundles assimilated with that old
Universe this is why this new episode
opens with a slightly different version
of the post credit scene that we got
during season 2's get shwifty episode
with this new water tea of season 7's
parmesian Universe experiencing
different last words from King magma Q
than Dimension c131 water tea did in
season 2 in this rise of the new
maricons episode water T's father gives
his son the eye of Harmony as his last
act while season 2 magma Q simply
apologizes to water te for turning him
to ice season 2's magma Q is actually
called helium Q in that universe so the
implication seems to be that this new
water tea did not experience the
bigheaded croman invasion in the same
way that Rick and Morty did in
dimenstion c131 so this water te has
likely never heard Rick and Morty
perform get schwifty at all and likely
learned his lesson of caring some other
way another big difference between these
two scenes is that magma Q is actually
voiced by rapper Ice Tea in this new
episode with Dan Harmon reprising his
role as water tea once again but anyways
as the numeric cons descend onto alphab
betrium this calculator themed spaceship
here has the number 58008 at the top
which of course spells the word boobs if
you turn the calculator upside down one
of the few sources of Joy us Junior boob
lovers of the world had while learning
math in element elementary school then
as the booby ship starts to wreak havoc
across the city you can see a letter K
walking a letter D dog as well as a
motherly uppercase M with her lowercase
b baby which I thought was kind of funny
but unfortunately for that baby b would
stand for blown the [__] up as nobody
outside that Cafe would survive which
makes sense considering that one of the
numeron generals yells divide and
conquer zero survivors which would be
the first of a vast number of numerical
puns that these aliens have in their
Arsenal aliens clearly modeled after the
evil Decepticon race from the
Transformers Animated franchise from the
1980s as well as the Empire from Star
Wars even this episode's intro title
drop is themed with the font of 1986's
Transformers the movie and even parody
The Rock intro music of that movie as
well after water te crunches some
numbers he hops into lithium P spaceship
called the glyph jumper which is an
alphabet themed parody of the autobot
cliff jumper from Transformers with
lithium P's name of course being a
reference to Lithium Polymer batteries
then they both fly directly to Mr
goldenfold's high school math class
where all these kids are struggling to
learn second grade level math apparently
I mean look at this class decor and
chalkboard 1 + 5 equals question mark
really everybody over the age of seven
knows that the answer is 15 idiots and
yet somehow Morty still ends up being Mr
goldenfold's worst student of all time
even more so than iced tea who used to
wear a Pac-Man shirt in Mr goldenfold's
class in the 1980s in order to fit in
with his 1980s classmates but actually
real life IC te graduated crenchaw high
school in 1976 before briefly joining
the Army in 1979 so he would not be in
high school in the80s but anyways after
water te crashes surprise detention and
has Mr goldenfold look over the eye of
Harmony that's literally designed after
a lowercase eye Sinar 7 and her number
sign themed type Strikers attack the
school with those type Strikers also
being themed after the Tie fighters from
Star Wars and even make similar SAR
sounds to those iconic Star Wars ships
as well also it seems that Sinar 7
herself was purposely made a number
seven by the Rick and Morty team in
order to show that this character was
meant to be water T's numeric
counterpart as the number seven is the
letter T and the elite speak inent
alphabet the alphabet that frequently
uses numbers to mean letters like how
the number three can be the letter e or
how the number five looks like the
letter s but anyways in response to
Sinar 7's surprise attack Morty and Mr
Golden escape on the glyph jumper after
lithium P cranks that hyphen drive to
enter helvetica light speed Star Wars
Style with helvetica light speed of
course being a reference to the popular
font helvetica light this leads Sinar 7
to report to Lord dreadn on her new
marican parody of a star destroyer with
the ship itself being a greater than
sign to represent how they feel greater
than all those other races as she enters
the chamber you can see four and six
numerical guards wearing cloaked red
armor like the emper Emperor's Royal
Guard does in these Star Wars movies
before Lord dreadnut himself appears in
a massive blue hologram just like
Palpatine and supreme leader snoke do in
those movies as well dreadn even shoots
out lightning at Sinar 7 much like
Palpatine shocks everyone in his life
like Darth Vader Lord dreadn is also of
course themed after a slashed zero which
has been historically used for centuries
in order to differentiate zeros from the
letter O which is a letter that you
don't want to be mistaken for if you
happen to be an emperor of a society of
racist digits but anyways when we get
another flashback to water Tea's earlier
days as the human ice tea we can see the
rapper eating some Cheetos before Mr
goldenfold helps IC te achieve enough
flow to record his 1988 hit song colors
then we get a Back to the Future parody
of Marvin Barry's famous fake phone call
to Chuck Barry after Marty McFly shreds
at his parents' dance and later when we
see the bracket Shields of alphab
betrium weeken all the letters watching
The Shield levels are scared as hell all
the letters except for this relaxed
letter r who's just smiling there like
he just took a big hit of some dank
alphabet lettuce I've been there man
I've been there ain't nothing wrong with
that water T then informs the secretly
evil oxygen s that the eye of Harmony
has been translated and when he does I
notice that oxygen s's staff is looped
with an infinity symbol foreshadowing
his Ascension into the destructive
Cosmic being Infinity then later as
Sinar 7 attacks the glyph jumper she
yells threesus Christ after water T
shoots back before both ships crash land
on planet E10 which continues the Star
Wars parody Theme by being a parody of
the Ewok Moon of Endor from Return of
the Jedi the native squiggly Doodles of
the region even bow down to the golden
eye of Harmony like the Ewoks worshiped
the golden C3PO with the funniest
Doodles of the bunch of course being the
cocka doodle Doodles shaped like you
know [__] they're they're [__] they're
[__]
Doodles sorry but after the tea with the
Glock is awoken by the Cox he finds that
sinister star 7 has stolen the eye of
Harmony leading water tea Morty and Mr
goldenfold to chase after her but of
course Mr goldenfold does the
gentlemanly thing and leaves his car
behind with an alien doodle that he
might have impregnated the night before
with the words Mr goldenfold math
teacher at the top of the card and his
phone number on the bottom then shortly
after this we all get the immense
displeasure of having to see the letter
T and the number seven 69 themselves
into a cosmic vision of their shared
Origins before Emperor dreadn arrives on
the scene with oxygen s who was secretly
an evil ass eight this entire time an
evil ass eight who ends up betraying his
King to become an all powerful Cosmic
being much like Jafar portrays the
sultan to do the same in the Aladdin
movie they even subtly themed eight
snake patterns off of jafar's Cobra form
from that movie as well which I found to
be a very nice touch but anyways when
Infinity goes and attacks alphab betrium
a letter c that looks like cheese calls
the event an apostrophe rather than a
catastrophe a catastrophe that that
water tea of course stops with the power
of music much like Rick and Morty did
with get schwifty in Season 2 well you
know also With a Little Help From a
cosmic bullet to infiniti's left nut
which we see travel through infiniti's
body in a visual similar to when baby
grw travels through ego's body to reach
his brain and Guardians too then of
course after infinity is defeated both
magma T and Sinar combine their races to
form the new hybrid Planet Alfa numeron
a planet that gets visited by rapper Ice
Cube who apparently has secretly been a
transforming geometron this entire time
with Ice Cube of course making the
iconic transforming noise that all the
Transformers make in the Animated Series
but that's it gang thank you guys so
much for watching this breakdown of
episode 8 of season 7 of Rick and Morty
you can follow me at mastertainment on
Twitter and Instagram or wherever I am
on the internet but most importantly
don't forget to subscribe to heavy
spoilers today because we always got
some amazing stuff for you guys and you
don't want to miss out do you do you
want to miss out you don't okay you
don't want to do that I'm trying to
activate your fomo right now is it
activated good hit that subscribe button
maybe even hit that like button too if
you're feeling generous really helps out
the channel man just saying but again
thanks again for watching this video you
guys are amazing and I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time now
if you excuse me I'm going to go
69 you can't 69 by yourself so that's a
lie goodbye